the number of founders I've talked to
who basically said some version of we're
not growing as fast as cursor so
therefore we should pivot or do another
idea and when you look you're like you
have the best product in your category
like for some reason I feel like
sometimes founders kind of think
startups are just kind of fungeible you
know it's like oh I could make Door Dash
or I could make like GitLab and it's
like that's not been my experience
like
this is Dalton Puss Michael today we're
going to talk about a topic on every
founder's mind. So, Dalton, I'm not
growing 10x year-over-year. That means I
should shut my company down and go get a
job at Google, right? Because I saw in
Twitter that investors will only invest
in me if I get you.
>> Yeah, I think Andrees put out a video
saying if you don't have that, your
company is bad or I forget what they
said.
>> If I were to parody it, cuz I don't
remember it exactly. It's like if I
don't have a millionaire or R in the
first week, it's just like it's over for
me and like my life prospects are bad
now. I'm like married or have kids. I
felt like that was great marketing by
the way. Like as an aside, like ragebait
marketing in practice, everyone's
talking about E16Z now, right? I was
like, I don't know if that's the Hey,
>> look, all media is good media, right?
Okay,
>> so anyways, let's try to unpack this a
little bit. What's going on? Companies
are growing faster
>> than we've seen in the B2B SAS era, for
sure. Maybe not faster than we saw in
the consumer era, but we can that aside
a little bit, but certainly um that's
happening. What What What's going on? I
think we should try to steal man um both
extremes here. So, let's talk about the
growth is real side of the coin. Well,
>> if you go look at the app store, OpenAI
has been number one in the app store for
the past couple years. Right now, I
think Sora is number one, which is also
OpenAI.
>> And holy cow is the revenue growth real
and the consumer growth real of AI
tools.
>> Yeah.
>> And B2B tools that are using the APIs.
Yeah.
>> Is real. Well, and and and you're saying
from the revenue side, from the product
side, the OpenAI product is 10x better
than anything that existed remotely
similar to it 5 years ago.
>> Imagine if you imagine you had a time
machine.
>> Yeah.
>> And you gave someone access to this.
>> And they would just be like cooking,
right?
>> It's like pretty good, right? It's like
now everyone has it.
>> Like giving someone Google in like the
late 80s.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's on the plus side. on the minus
side, what what's going like I'm quoting
someone, I forgot where I read it, but
it's sort of like these days annual
recurring revenue is often
>> not annual nor recur recurring nor
revenue.
>> So every aspect of the term is wrong. So
basically you see a lot of creative
accounting.
>> Yes.
>> Where people are, you know, reselling
API calls to Anthropic. They're upside
down on it. They're multiplying the
numbers by 12 to make an annual number.
Have it be non-recurring. It's actually
just run rate revenue. There's all this
like [__] creative accounting going
on.
>> Let's let's go down in that like so much
deeper. Okay. Right. So it's like all
right, I'm running a service that has a
monthly subscription. Annualizing that
is an estimate because I could cancel it
any
>> that is correct.
>> I'm running a service that has like a
usage rate like AWS. We're like I can
pull all of my files from S3 tomorrow
and never pay Amazon another cent. Turn
that into AR is a little hokey. I don't
want to name names, but there are a
large number of products that YC
founders use that I've spoken about, and
they say things like, if I were to pay
for the tokens to do this directly with
OpenAI or Claude, it would cost this.
This product charged me this divided by
two. I like using AI, but
why not get a 50% discount per token? So
point being, there's a lot of creative
accounting for how you define growth
rates. Yes. Um there's people that are,
you know, maybe you have an LOI, maybe
you have like a email, oh we're going to
definitely use your thing and then you
count that as ARR. Y
>> big pilots. I've definitely seen like
impressive logo on website. Dig in and
it's like it's a big pilot. It's a
million-dollar pilot.
>> Yeah.
>> But like I've seen situations where
they're doing pilots with six companies.
So their logo's on six different and
it's like is that an enterprise deal? Is
is that like a locked in scalable thing
or was that just kind of we're demoing
it and seeing what's going on?
>> Yeah. And so the point is the following.
Are there startups that are actually
growing at 5x or 10x, you know, greater
than 5x year, 10x year? Yes.
>> Especially at small scale.
>> Definitely.
>> Yes.
>> Are there startups that go from zero to
a million ARR in some form or another
faster than we've seen in the past?
Yeah.
>> Yes. And I think partially, we've talked
about this before, but it's because big
companies are willing to purchase the
stuff
>> and it used that used to be really hard
to get a big logo
>> and and they don't mind spending money.
If they can see value, they don't mind
spending money.
>> Yeah. So that that's real.
>> Yes.
>> Um but I think if you're a founder and
you're depressed and you're like ready
to shut down your company because you're
only growing 6x year over year, don't do
it.
>> No, that's or like just like a 16Z.
That's just like self-defeating bad
memes. Um,
>> I think the best way to think about this
from an investor perspective
>> is that you're going to be judged
relative to your direct peers.
>> And so, let's say that you're doing
voice AI, vertical voice AI,
>> you are going to be judged based on how
fast the other vertical voice AI
companies are growing. Because if you're
an investor like, right, like I'm I'm
running a series A firm.
>> You're picking them a lot. I'm looking
at a lot of companies that are building
in the space. Maybe not competitors, but
>> they're comparables. Yeah.
>> And yeah, I am looking on a relative
basis. Yes.
>> How the companies are doing compared to
each other, but I'm also taking the time
to dig into how real the contracts are.
I'm digging into if the product is good.
Like there's all this nuance that as an
investor that I would dig into.
>> Yes.
>> And so the way I would extrapolate this
as a founder is realize who your
comparables are.
>> Realize who you're going to be judged
against. Yes. And if you want to be able
to keep raising, be better than average.
>> I love that you're talking about these
comps because the number of founders
I've talked to who basically said some
version of we're not growing as fast as
cursor. So therefore, we should pivot or
do another idea. And when you look,
you're like, you're not even in a space
that could support this level. Like, you
know, like you sell enterprise software,
it's not self-s served. Like, yep. How
would you be able to grow as f like or
you're growing you have the best product
in your category like why would you care
about cursor? It's a completely
different category and for some reason I
feel like sometimes founders kind of
think startups are just kind of funible
you know it's like oh I could make Door
Dash or I could make like GitLab and
it's like that's not been my experience
like you you probably couldn't have made
either but like it's probably much more
likely you would have made one than
both. And so, um, I think when people
don't look at the comps, that's when
they can psych themselves out.
>> Yep.
>> I also think that there's a bit of a
question about what phase are we in. I
think you and I have this kind of really
interesting perspective because we've
seen multiple cycles now because we're
old as [__] And like I think that we
just experienced very latestage B2B SAS,
which I would argue is like at least I
found fairly depressing. But like, you
know, it was he the technology hasn't
changed for years, right? And now we're
in this kind of probably a cycle that to
us would feel like early web apps or
early mobile apps. And I think sometimes
people don't understand like how little
things have firmed up yet. Like when the
game's early like
>> Yeah.
>> Like it's hard to predict what will have
stay power.
>> Hard to predict what will have network
effects.
>> Yes. And I am fully expecting to be
surprised. I know that's a weird way to
think about it.
>> Yeah. I don't trust my ability to
predict
>> no
>> what is enduring and what isn't. It's
kind of like do do you remember the vet
that Sam made
>> where he was like these YC companies
together will be worth like X billion
dollars.
>> And if you look at the list of
companies, there's some really good
stuff in there. I think Stripe was on
the list. But then there was like
Teespring.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And like it's because at the I remember
at the time it was taking off. Stripe
and Teespring seems like equally good
startups to me.
>> And so even when you're completely in
the no
>> Yeah.
>> It's hard to to predict what's going to
be sticky and what's going to be the
enduring company.
>> I love that you said expect to be
surprised because like if we think back
through 20 25 years in tech, how many
name brands
have we seen just [__] remember Palm?
Yeah. Yahoo is one of the biggest
companies in the world and now it's just
like this like ad tech stuff.
>> No, it's a different thing.
>> Yeah. AOL, Netscape, like there's so
many examples. And what's funny is it's
like when you think about some of those
examples, it wasn't they're going to
win.
>> It was like the game was declared over.
>> Yeah.
>> Like by the time Google was going, Yahoo
was already declared the winner.
>> Yep. And
>> it was like the biggest and most
important internet company
>> literally. Yeah. And then somehow it un
won. There is no kind of like permanent
winner.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh except Microsoft that
>> but um I think this is what when
founders discourage themselves like man
just take a look at some of the like
dinosaurs and like you might realize
something that looks great today. You
have no idea what the shelf life is.
>> Yeah. And and again to for the record I
have no idea how sticky cursor is versus
cloud code and stuff. I mean, again,
we'll make investments on stuff like
this, but if you feel like, "Okay,
Dalton, bet your life on what's going to
happen and what's sticky." I don't know.
>> At this phase,
>> I have no idea.
>> It's like the dumbest moment to
>> I don't know what's going to stick. I to
me, I think like the lesson I learned
from YC in these phase, fun smart people
and just see what happens.
>> Yeah. Smart people will figure out.
>> Yeah. And like lean back. And like maybe
my take away from more later shade shots
was like the variance is a little bit
less um can't predict necessarily who's
going to win, but the variance in
outcomes is way way less. Whereas now I
don't know that we know how to even use
the tools we have right now. You know,
it's like the I always talk about this
example of like how long did it take us
to squeeze the most out of a mobile
phone? How long did it take us to
squeeze the most out of a web browser?
Like the idea that a new model drops and
we know the best way to extract value
out of it is like the biggest joke I've
ever experienced. And maybe the most
positive or actionable thing from
hearing this like, oh, everyone's
growing faster than me is I did see a
couple of companies apply to Standard
Capital at our last funding cycle
>> where it was a company that had been
around two or three years
>> and it wasn't really growing fast and so
they did like a crazy pivot nine months
ago and it totally worked. Okay, that
was pretty smart. Yep.
>> Does that make sense? Like I saw people
do
>> AI pivots that were well thought through
even though they're
>> two or three years in their startup.
>> Yes.
>> And I and I asked them, well, why why
did you do this? And like, well, we
weren't growing fast enough. Yeah.
>> Okay, that's that's fair game.
>> I think this has been a bit of a and and
we'll see how it works out. But I've
definitely seen people who like I would
describe as had some interesting
insights but poor tools as the B2B SAS
thing kind of came to a close where like
with AI they can actually do they can
create way more value for the customer.
So like oh like yeah we got this
contract with the customer and like we
can do this much and then we wake up and
it's like oh it turns out we can do this
much for our customer. Oh now they want
to talk to us more. Like oh we're get
we're getting meetings we weren't
getting before. Oh, we're making them
more money. Like, and it's like, yeah,
you got better tools. Like, get back in
the game. You got better tools, right?
It's like, you got better pads. Go hit
hard. Now, I think that um anyone who's
discouraged. It's like, man, better
tools are coming out every day. This is
a great time to be doing it. Don't get
discouraged by someone. Make it a
>> Don't be discouraged and don't be
accepting of slow growth.
>> Exactly. Be inspired. With great tools,
you should be able to go faster than
before. All right. Great chat. All
right. Thanks, Michael. Thank you.